when we take moments to identify our
growth point meaning how we can be
better
we Inspire those around us to do the
same and so when we do that there's that
exponential impact where those around us
get a better vision of what they see for
themselves and we're living our best
life and so my vision is to see that
come through and everything that I do
every decision I make
um every client I work with in the
organization I'm with today welcome to
20 minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
let's talk about growth today I am with
Amy Clark an executive coach and Human
Resources leader who provides meaningful
management and leadership development
coaching that drives measurable business
outcomes she has more than 20 years of
valuable corporate business experience
at various Fortune 500 companies and
National non-profit organizations
serving in positions such as vice
president of talent management and Chief
Human Resources officer Amy has a deep
passion for connecting with and
developing others and as an
all-in-thought partner with a track
record of being in the trenches and
walking alongside leaders she has
invaluable first-hand experience that
has informed her belief that coaching
people on skills drives transformative
change in people as a leadership
development coach she works one-on-one
with Visionary growth-minded leaders to
identify key behaviors they want to gain
awareness of and help them understand
what they can do today to be more
successful tomorrow
[Music]
Amy Clark welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here how are
you I'm doing great thank you Michael
it's great to be here with you
thank you for joining me where are you
joining me from right now besides the
beautiful bookshelf that's behind you
shelf we reside in northern Delaware
Middletown Delaware so uh about a 30
miles south of Philadelphia something
like that all right awesome and uh and
uh you know you are very dedicated to
and growth mindset so much so that you
have founder and executive coach at the
growth minded leadership group and with
a lot of experience with different
organizations working on you know
different talent management Human
Resources growth mindset in general and
so I'm excited to you know I unfold your
passion and curiosity for the subject
together in these 20 short but
meaningful minutes and so we'll we'll
have to just Dive Right In Amy tell me a
little bit about your relationship with
talent management and growth mindset in
general
well it comes across you know in in the
years of you know experience that I've
been in business and
um you know having you know the
opportunity to walk alongside leaders in
the work that they do with their teams
um you know and how
really leadership shows up as a way to
inspire yourself and Inspire others you
know to Greatness and and what's
possible
and you know so I I think it's it's
certainly evolved been reimagined over
the time and in the course of my career
in in human resources and and you know I
would say over the last five years you
know talent management has has surfaced
even Warren saying you know as we think
about the environment that changes
around us being ready for the challenges
that could come up
um how do we really help people see
their potential and step into that
potential
um so organizations that we support do
the same and and so I um you know for me
it's been something I've researched
delved into so much more and I think
mostly in the experiences that I've had
with leaders over the years
um been very rewarding and given me the
opportunity to Think Through
how do people grow and what does that
mean
all right that that's really cool well
what have you sort of learned about
yourself so far you know in this in this
journey because I'm sure that as you
work with a lot of talent management a
lot of people especially talking about
growth mindset I'm sure you get to learn
quite a bit about yourself and this
journey as well yeah
um thank you for asking me that because
that is you know it's so true when
you're going through different
experiences
um
it is something that I in last year as
I've been as I wrote my book growth
point
you know I went back into history of my
life and what my influencers are and you
know I think and and all of us thinking
about growth for ourselves it's going
back to our upbringing what are those
personal experiences that have formed us
to what we are today and can continue to
form what we do in the future and and
for me you know it it really started
with being the youngest of seven
children and being humming naturally
observant
you know watching them learning what
they do what I should say what I should
not do yeah it's so thank them for
giving me those lessons before I you
know I was the one that kind of okay
maybe I won't do that
um but you know what what it did is I
yeah that's really and I didn't know it
then you know you don't know it at that
time but when you look back on that you
know I become to realize that I'm just a
naturally curious observant person and
it's and I look at people I'm like how
did they get to where they are what did
they do differently or you know what was
their mindset to get that to that point
and so for me I've learned that about
myself and how to really step into that
more and embrace that as something
that's just that helps me be my best
um and serve those that count on what I
do so I I think you know it's it's all
of us to have the opportunity to learn
from our upbringing experiences of the
past
um to help us really just Embrace Who We
Are
wow that's really really cool and and
what is the role of
growth mindset if you will in achieving
what you just described
well I I'd like to explain it is
you believe that you can further develop
your innate skills and abilities that
you've had since your childhood that
you've acquired over time
so let me first say you know the
other side of the spectrum of growth
mindset is one is affixed you know so
this is what I know this is what I do
um this is what I'm good at
and you know fixed mindset uses phrases
like well I don't know how to do that
I've never done that before I failed at
that and we all have moments when we say
that so I'm not suggesting because you
know I've said we have you know I failed
at that one
a growth mindset is this flip of a
switch and really the script if you will
I'm saying
you know I don't know how to do that yet
yeah
um and when you didn't you made a
mistake or you failed at something and
it's saying you know what can I learn
from this experience
um and it's also putting yourself out
there to say who else can I learn from
um and and again it's about this belief
that
you can be better the belief that you
are successful today you will continue
to be successful and you know this the
steps to take in you know you can grow
you know there's more that you can
develop and improve upon so so that's
where it comes from and
um it shows up in everybody and in some
way shape or form
but having a growth mindset
is one because when we think about our
contribution to the world it begins with
our growth and so if we're thinking in
the mindset of growth we're able to
expand our contributions for ourselves
and for those that you know we encounter
on a day-to-day basis
and so if you know as you encounter
people in your own journey in your own
work what type of work do you do with
people in this regard because I mean it
sounds very very powerful and got to
read quite a quite a bit on the
literature on this how what is sort of
your
with your your role in participating
with people's active
um you know journey I would say yeah
yeah absolutely yeah the the the
beautiful thing about what I get to do
so I I lead HR for an incredible
non-profit organization and I am a
founder and CEO of um growth minded
leadership group and you know in both of
those I really
I get to work with leaders every day and
you know when I say the word leaders
it's a broad term okay this is not
necessarily people that have people on
their teams I believe leadership is
about inspiring yourself and those
around you and you are a leader
um and and so the work I do with them is
um is is around a process of
change but taking a Visionary approach
to your growth and and so in the
day-to-day work I do often encounter
folks like I'm not sure what to do or
I I really didn't show up the way I
needed to show up or I need help
and those are moments where people have
identified what I like to call growth
point you know you you've reached this
point where saying okay wait a minute
there's something different here and I
think we can all say we've had that and
then we say that we're go on with our
day and then there's nothing done with
it
the process I'd like to use for people
is help them create their vision for
growth what they Envision for self and
their future and how they can learn more
about themselves so when they're in the
moments that I've just described they
can look back and say
you know if I did do something
differently how does it help me realize
the future I want to see for myself
and so I work with leaders in a variety
of capacities whether it's in a formal
development program casual conversation
like we're having here or through formal
coaching engagements to help them create
their playlists for how they can be
better tomorrow and
um and that is first starting with your
vision
um and you know ways that you can listen
for growth point moments to help you get
there
wow and so the the types of people that
you get to work with well how do you
sort of describe their no the different
archetypes
well it's it this process
you know say approach works with people
that again believe they are successful
and they believe they can learn more and
they want to
you need to have a desire right how do
you how to identify that
their their want and desire yeah I mean
is it is it enough for someone to say
that they want to or no it's not but you
know what people will and you know you
and and so here's the thing you know my
role as a coach
I I it's not to force something on
somebody it's to say so what are you
looking to achieve
it's really starting with their
awareness their why their purpose okay
and so once you do that and you help
them amplify their awareness of how they
are today they begin to see some gaps
like oh I see how doing that is not
helping me
okay so so what are some steps
that you think you can take to help you
there and so we all have good intentions
different goals things we want to do
right and so we establish a structure to
that and you know what happens I think
like with some many goals and habits we
want to form things seem to fall off
and I think you start to notice where do
you really want that because if the
people are not making progress or not
putting the effort forward you know you
said this was important to you
and that this would help you get there
so how do we help you get from here to
there or has something changed for you
again it's it's it's all about someone's
desire and if they're like you know what
this is not what I need okay let's start
again let's start again but I think you
know yeah I've had those moments where
people have
um
you know I would say fallen off and kind
of say you know I I just can't focus on
this right now and you can't force the
issue with people it comes in their own
time you got to meet people where they
are you're not gonna be successful in
that and it's not about me it's about
them and their journey and it's
important to remember that
and key challenges that you observe that
people have along this journey
that's a simple process just not easy to
do yeah um you know I mean when you
think about because when we think about
becoming better and growing
um
it requires us to form new routines and
habits
and just like any you know we we're just
accustomed to the Comfort
and so I would say it's getting outside
of that comfort
and
reminding yourself that it's worth your
effort and so I think that's the biggest
challenge is actually the doing
because life gets in the way the other
things get in the way that cause
distraction and that's where some
regular coaching engagements and
conversations with someone that you can
say you know I set out to do this and I
just didn't and so what kind of in your
way and how can you do it different next
time
um but you know our human condition is
like that it's it's it's not an easy
thing to do when you look at the process
well yeah I can do that
and you know I've I found that myself I
mean just things that I'm I do you know
you but you have to go back to the
reason why you're doing it in the first
place
how do we take this now more to an
organizational approach
um from an organization's perspective
you know what what should you know in
your opinion should leaders keep in mind
or do you have any examples of
successful you know transitions or types
of you know different experiences that
people have had that transformed
organizations because it sounds like
this it's you know they're a powerful
concept and yeah how they get translated
towards organizational behavior
well it it starts with you know the
organization what the organization's
vision is and what the organization
values okay so if if there is not this
core Foundation of we value
um you know the growth of our people we
we value and we are focused on serving
on our mission our promise to the people
that purchase our product buyer you know
buy our services in order to do that we
need to you know Stand Up and Grow the
people within our organization and so it
needs to start with the the business
case if you will the vision if you will
from the leadership of the organization
to say this is important and we are
going to focus on this we are going to
ensure space is created for you to do
this and develop
um in the role that you're in
um because it's for the health of the
organization really if you don't do that
you're left wondering how you're going
to meet the challenges that come around
the corner the things that are
unexpected and and so what I have found
um and my experience is you know
starting with the values piece of
helping leaders identify what they value
connecting it to what the organization
values and how people can add to that
and and and see here here are some of
the aspirational things here are some
things that we can get to and people
become inspired
um and as you connected to what the
Strategic plan is for the organization
the vision for the organization people
then can start to connect the impact
they have to that
um and so what I've what I've seen work
best
um in what I've done in the organization
you know what organization I'm with too
is it starts with that c-suite executive
leadership team you know I've taken
leadership teams through you know
development programs to say this is what
leadership is for us and defining that
be part of what does leadership mean
when we say our values what does that
actually mean
when we say we we support the
development of our people
what is development and to what end what
can people expect because you want to
set out those definitions so people
understand you know here are some of the
paths that I can take and then of course
taking that leadership team through the
very Central components of an effective
leadership and then I've worked it into
line management
and then broader in the organization so
there's some common ground and common
language as far as what success means
and growth means in organization so
um you know those are some of the things
that I've worked on and seen you know
some profound results in
um and working with teams yeah that's
really really cool
talking about your own Vision you know
if you had to
sort of distill your vision for your
worth or personally know what what is it
what is Amy's Vision here
well it comes back to how we make a
contribution and it's how we view our
growth and so when we take moments to
identify our growth point meaning how we
can be better
um we Inspire those around us to do the
same
and so when we do that there's that
exponential impact where those around us
get a better vision of what they see for
themselves and we're living our best
life and so my vision is to see that
come through and everything that I do
every decision I make
um every client I work with in the
organization I'm with today
um that our contribution begins with how
we view our growth and viewing our
growth in a growth mindset way
helps us all be better and um
bringing in ways practical ways in which
for people to do that that they see is
reasonable is inspirational as well
um you know is is something that I focus
on as well
yeah and if you if you think about you
know what what it would take for
you know someone to to bring delivery
for example young entrepreneurs coming
and taking these ideas and bringing them
into to the organization or to
themselves or to their own community
perhaps what are some things that we
shouldn't be keeping in mind you know
ourselves as we want to take these
mindsets and not just leverage them
ourselves but also Empower others around
us to have more of a growth mindset
well I think it first comes down to you
know it centers around a change process
because it is a different way of it may
be a different way of thinking for
people and if it's not a different way
of thinking for people it is rallying
people around a common cause and purpose
of it and so first it's saying it's it's
as an entrepreneur
being clear on your vision having a
compelling vision for what you want to
see in the future
um for your business and the people that
are part of what you're going to do the
people that you count on
um and when you have a clear and
compelling Vision meaning
you have set out and understand what you
believe in
you have answered you know who benefits
from what you do
and the impact it will have
creates this balance for you as an
entrepreneur of where you need to place
focus in building your business and
sustaining its value and growth over
time and so to me if you don't have that
it's very difficult to move on with
other things you know it's like you know
as I have worked with people over the
years
um if you're not clear in your why and
your purpose you just can't really get
to anything else yeah yeah well Amy
thank you so much for this time and uh
for sharing your your insights and your
journey with me over these 20 minutes uh
definitely going to be taking a lot of
these approaches myself and hopefully
others listening also enjoyed it as well
so so thank you very very much Amy best
of luck in in you know the different
people that you work with in the
organizations you work with as well yeah
and and I look forward to keeping in
touch and cheering from the side so
thank you very much
thank you Michael I have enjoyed our
conversation thank you
[Music]